I'm a huge fan of Udacity.
At a point in my career,
I was doing a lot of business development.
I've always been super excited about technology,
I've always been super technically inclined,
but I always felt a little bit like I was sitting on the sidelines.
I felt Udacity really gave me quickiest access for me to understand it.
I became fascinated and I fell in love with
coding and I said I'm going to just do these nanodegrees,
I'm going to understand,
I'm going to teach myself.
It was during my time that I was doing my full sack and data analysis.
Nanodegrees that I went online and started picking up solidity,
and doing my own self-directed solidity blockchain nanodegree on the side,
which is now a formalized program here which I'm so excited about.
I found out shortly after joining Kadena that all of
the management team and the founders didn't go through a traditional computer science.
None of them have computer science degrees,
they were all self taught.
It was a very interesting realization that you don't
have to have a traditional university college degree to invent stuff.
Udacity gave me this skill set to learn
about the first principles of what computer science is.
I still go to Udacity to brush up on certain concepts.
I check out all of the courses coming out on a regular basis.
Udacity played such a formative role in shaping my understanding of
how to learn about technical issues and learn about new concepts
coming out that I really wanted to pull from a pool of people that have entered into
a program that self-selects for
self starters and people who are curious and are lifelong learners.